le vote par correspondance fera t-il son
grand retour pour les élections
municipales du 28 juin prochain
c'est en tout cas le souhait de
plusieurs élus locaux à l'image de
rachida dati candidate à la ville de
paris voté à distance en france c'était
possible avant de l'après guerre
jusqu'en 1975
un conseil pratique maintenant comment
voter par correspondance
voté par correspondance qu'une
possibilité n'est pas pour tout le monde
après la guerre seules quelques
personnes ayant droit de par leur statut
ou leur métier notamment les militaires
français à l'étranger où les personnes
hospitalisées en 1958
d'autres métiers y ont accès à
l'occasion des élections législatives
nous l'avons étendue à d'autres
nouvelles catégories comme les
journalistes en déplacement comme
également les transporteurs routiers
certains agents connaît également les
agents commerciaux pour voter par
correspondance
plusieurs conditions d'abord prendre
contact avec sa mairie puis justifier
son absence pour cela fournir une
attestation de son employeur ou un
certificat médical pour les personnes
hospitalisées pour voter par
correspondance
chez tout à la fois simple et assez
compliqué une démarche longue qui peut
s'avérer complexe pour certains en 1973
ce soudeur originaire du nord de la
france travaillait à fos-sur-mer dans
les bouches-du-rhône difficile pour lui
d'aller voter aux élections législatives
comment cela ce côté ça passait pour
vous lors des élections du 4 mars à 20
pour les élections je suis du pas de
calais c'est un petit problème ou s'il
faut jamais un gendarme heures à la
mairie
en plus d'être fastidieux le vote par
correspondance à un autre inconvénient
majeur celui d'être peu sécurisé
bourrages d'urnes oublie de bulletins
faux certificats médicaux
les incidents sont nombreux comme en
1975 à ajaccio cette année-là des
fraudes avaient été constatées lors des
élections municipales complémentaires
les incidents hier à ajaccio lors du
dépouillement des votes par
correspondance de l'élection municipale
complémentaire les contestations
éclatèrent est un des adjoints au maire
dû s'asseoir sur mu sommes pour la
protéger fit appel à la police
ellle une échauffourée suite à ces abus
le vote par correspondance a été
supprimée en 1975
remplacé par le vote par procuration
aujourd'hui seuls les français de
l'étranger peuvent voter à distance mais
uniquement pour les élections
législatives
[Musique]